[Música]
na minha família a hospitalidade é
sinônimo de comida
então quando a gente vai receber alguém
ou vai comemorar alguma coisa sempre tem
comida não é pouca comida
é muita comida quando você acha que você
já tá feito sempre tem alguém para
colocar algo mais no seu prato e você
ainda faz com amar me tinha do almoço de
domingo para garantir jantar
então na minha casa a estabilidade é
comer ea gente trata nossos problemas de
todas as nossas coisas com comida
eu tive a oportunidade de viajar é e com
14 anos eu fui morar na tailândia fiz
intercâmbio e fui morar lá e foi uma das
experiências mais incríveis da minha
vida porque eu tive que reaprender tudo
tudo o que eu sabia até os meus 14 anos
teve que ser reaprendido naquele momento
de usar o banheiro ao conceito de morte
então eu cheguei na tailândia fiquei
três dias em bancoc com todos os outros
intercambistas e depois peguei um trem
de bancoc até a última cidade da
tailândia bem no norte chamada xangai
cheguei na minha família e cheguei na
casa onde eu ia morar por volta da meia
noite eles me apresentaram o meu quarto
e sumiram foram cada um dormiu e eu não
achava o banheiro e eu comecei a abrir
um monte de portas e não achava o
banheiro então olha que abre uma porta
de uma varanda externa no segundo andar
e achei isso ali uma bacia sanitária um
tanque pequeno e um tanque grande não
tinha chuveiro não tinha pia e eu olhei
para ele e falei tá primeiro primeiro
pensamento foi tá que eu estou fazendo
aqui
o segundo foi tá como é que eu uso isso
então foi um reaprendizado completo
aquela foto ali a maior eu estou
constrangida na frente de um túmulo como
o tailandesa é budista e acredita
em reencarnação em karma morrer
significa que você vai para um outro
lugar para um lugar melhor
então existe uma celebração existe todo
uma comemoração desse momento e você é
então tira fotos na frente do túmulo
celebra enfim então foi todo esse
aprendizado
mas uma das coisas que mais me chamou a
atenção foi é a hospitalidade tailandesa
aos tailandeses é muito diferente da
nossa é não existe o toque você não
beija não abraça
mas o sorriso de um tailandês é uma das
coisas mais aconchegante que existe
eles são genuinamente acolhedores e de
novo porque eles são acolhedores por
causa da religião eles acreditam que
quando você serve alguém quando você
acolhe alguém você constrói karma
positivo então servir é na verdade uma
dádiva então esse foi um contato com a
hospitalidade
depois eu tive a oportunidade de morar
na áustria e ea gente tem esse
estereótipo do alemão do áustria com
muito mais seco muito mais duro na
verdade não foi isso que eu encontrei lá
eu encontrei o que eu chamo de
hospitalidade cidadã que é aquela em que
quem serve e quem é servido tem o mesmo
status que recebi é tão legal quanto ser
recebido
então assim todas as pessoas que
cumprimentam o serviço é super eficaz
mas existe uma relação de igualdade
entre quem está prestando serviço e quem
está recebendo então isso foi um
aprendizado muito legal uma vez cheguei
numa loja as 1750 e pedir pra provar uma
peça ea vendedora falou claro amanhã
porque assim a gente fecha às 18 horas e
eu não vou conseguir atender
adequadamente então existe esse respeito
entre quem serve quem é servido mais
tarde ainda fui morar na espanha e
apesar do espanhol ser um pouco mais
ranzinza e não naturalmente
hospitaleiros mas também existe uma
hospitalidade quase festiva até parecida
com a nossa muito relacionada com a
comida
e enfim então esse é um processo de a
gente aprender as diversas formas de
hospitalidade e eu escolhi fazer da
hospitalidade a minha carreira é
trabalhar com com hotelaria gastronomia
e turismo é na verdade entregar essa
hospitalidade e em um dos hotéis que eu
trabalhei na minha história a gente
recebia todos os chefes de estado e de
governo que vinham para o brasil então
em um ano é receber 32 chefes de estado
e essa é uma hospitalidade protocolar é
uma cidade altamente ensaiada em que
tudo tem que ser cronometrado em que
cada gesto tem que ser pensado um chefe
de estado desse está vindo para assinar
um acordo comercial
você tem que entregar o que o país tem
de melhor para ele mas ao mesmo tempo
você tem que também entender o que ele
quer o que ele acredita qual é a cultura
dele quando a gente recebeu vladimir
putin
ele trouxe média todos os carros da
comitiva vieram da rússia e ele pediu
pra que xampu sabonete desodorante do
quarto dele fossem todos de uma
determinada marca é e aí a gente estava
com todos os seguranças da equipe dele
antes de eu chegar e os seguranças
entravam no apartamento para fazer a
verificação e todo mundo saia com o
mesmo cheiro então eles usavam era
compartilhado o item de banheiro é
quando a gente recebeu o emir do qatar a
gente teve que reconstruir o banheiro
ele é um homem de dois por dois e que
precisava de suporte então todo o
banheiro foi reformado para garantir o
atendimento das necessidades físicas dos
hábitos dele
então quando você recebe as pessoas você
precisa entender o que ela espera você
precisa entender qual é a necessidade
dela hospitalidade tem a ver com o outro
e aí o que falar da nossa hospitalidade
né da hospitalidade curitibana
muitos diriam que hospitalidade ea gente
pode não ser os mais efusivos no
elevador a gente realmente ainda precisa
desenvolver a nossa hospitalidade em
elevadores
mas uma coisa eu posso dizer com toda a
garantia
eu viajo o brasil inteiro ea viagem
praticamente todas as semanas
a gente tem uma hospitalidade sim que é
muito eficaz e o curitibano quando se
torna íntimo é um amigo e hospitaleiro
para a vida inteira daquele que você
pode pode contar até para esconder um
corpo
então eu acho que a gente tem que
impedir esse estereótipo começando dando
hoje no elevador então essa é a primeira
idéia deste ted que é bem o elevador é
mais falando nessa hospitalidade
por que que eu queria porque eu quero
falar sobre isso porque eu trouxe esse
tema porque pra mim hospitalidade é
acolhimento que é diferente de serviço
serviço que você faz pelo outro você
presta um serviço ao outro você atende o
outro hospitalidade é como você faz o
outro se sentir é o acolher o outro
fazer com que ele se sinta bem sendo
quem ele é
então hospitalidade é esse ato máximo de
acolhimento
quando a gente fala de hospitalidade no
meu entendimento a gente tem três
grandes coisas a atenção o respeito ea
empatia atenção porque você precisa
conhecer o outro precisa saber quais são
os desejos e as vontades dele você
precisa saber quais são as preferências
você precisa entender a cultura qual é
aquele ponto de vista
depois vem o respeito pra você entregar
alguma coisa para ele sem o teu juízo de
valor
respeitando aquelas preferências
respeitando aquela cultura respeitando
aquele hábito e isso também é ser
empático que é olhar para o outro e se
colocar no lugar dele não com o teu
filtro mas com o filtro do outro então
os qualidade é esse ato máximo de
acolher e é por isso que eu acredito que
a hospitalidade pode mudar o mundo
se a gente começar a acolher mais as
pessoas
a gente vai ter um mundo melhor a gente
consegue fazer com que a gente seja mais
respeitoso atencioso e empático porque
no mundo em que reiterou estão
protegidos pelas telas virtuais no mundo
em que os nossos representantes falam
atrocidades
o que a gente precisa de hospitalidade a
gente precisa de atenção de respeito e
empatia que não é possível que em 2019
alguém ainda não se sinta acolhido por
ser quem é
independente de gênero de raça de
sexualidade de opinião não é possível
que a gente não se sinta acolhido nesse
mundo por ser quem é
a gente tem que ter mais hospitalidade
que tal a gente começar já
levante e deu um abraço no colega do
lado
vocês são curitibanos eu sei é estranho
ah
olha gente rolou o excesso de
hospitalidade já tá todo mundo se
abraçando loma dinâmica
obrigada muito bem gente não lembra em
duas coisas vão acolher mais o outro e
vamos dar o elevador
obrigada
[Aplausos]